electrons build native desktop apps for
platforms like Mac OS and Windows using
nothing but HTML CSS and JavaScript it's
a tool behind many popular apps that you
might be using today like the s code
slack and discord just to name a few on
the front end you build UIs just like
you would for a browser-based web app
and you can bring along to our favorite
frameworks but an electron you also have
access to note J s and that means you
can access low-level API s that you
don't normally have access to in a
sandbox browser like the file system
electron combines the front end and back
end technologies and provides a bunch of
other tools to work with native menus
the system tray and so on
let's go ahead and build a desktop app
now run NPM in it in an empty directory
and install electron then create a
main.js file and set that as the main
entry point into your app every electron
app has exactly one main process running
it manages the lifecycle of your app and
opens the windows that the end user will
see each window is its own independent
render process running with the chromium
web browser when your main app is ready
you can start a new render process by
instantiating a browser window until the
window to load a regular HTML file it
will render the HTML CSS and JavaScript
but do so in a native window and give
you access to low-level api is to build
a true desktop experience create an
index.html file and put whatever code
you want inside of it but notice how i'm
accessing note Global's directly in my
HTML that's not something you can do in
a normal web browser an electron gives
you control over the operating system UI
as well for example add your own icon
and controls to the system tray with
just a few lines of code now after you
build something awesome you can package
it for multiple operating systems from a
single codebase tools like electron
packager or forage can handle the entire
distribution process for you with a
single command this has been electron in
100 seconds stay tuned for a full
electron project in a few days and make
sure to hit the like button if you want
to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]